what is your favorite organ to handle in
the human body ooh the brain
obviously really what happens when you
go six feet under well i'm talking about
that
today while watching six feet under with
a special guest
caitlyn dodie let's do it ask a
mortician
tell me how you found yourself in this
very
unique career position what drew you to
this field
i was always interested in death i went
to college at the university of chicago
i was a medieval history major there was
a lot
of death in the middle ages and that was
kind of my focus but i wanted to see
what happened
in real 20th century 21st century
american death got a job at a crematory
and i've been doing this for 13 years
now
and have never left wow oftentimes like
the subject of death is a very taboo
subject
how did you decide to start a youtube
channel on it and also approach it with
like
a respectful yet lighthearted manner
which i do with medicine all the time
it's very different when you're talking
about strictly death how did you find
yourself
here well i think it's probably some of
the same struggles that you have
which is knowing that a spoonful of
sugar helps the medicine go down you
want to create
like a cone of safety around what you're
doing so when they're watching
your channel people go oh wait a second
it's not
weird to have these questions it's not
wrong to have these questions or morbid
or
hypochondriac to have these questions
here we go
our first scene
well pretty good corpse i have to say
i have a lot of opinions about bad
corpses in television shows
this one i would say the blood the kind
of sallow
skin the sinking of the skin already i
think it's looking
pretty cool i don't know how many
corpses you see that's so funny that you
asked that because
i feel like i work on preventing people
from becoming corpses
and then unfortunately once they become
corpses i don't have much
dealings with them so i have less
experience and i'm gonna look for you to
guide me
on what would be a realistic corpse oh i
am so here i am here for you
top morticians rely on living splendor
embalming fluid
living splendor wow only real life
is better is this an infomercial within
the show
it's an infomercial within the show i
think these infomercials within
the show are trying to explain the
modern funeral industry a little bit and
this actually does a fantastic job there
are embalming fluids and humectant
fluids called things like
living splendor the way that they could
sell embalming and preservation to a
family
was by saying it's not only going to
preserve them it's going to keep you
safe and it's going to offer a lifelike
appearance which i happen to not agree
with i think a dead body should look
dead
because you know spoiler that's what
they are if you don't do
anything to the body the body has eyes
sort of like a
would be my demonstration of that like
that's a trokar do you know what that
does no in the embalming where you need
to remove
all of the cavity and organ fluid you
stab it in down by the belly button and
it has a sucking function
so you're stabbing and it's sucking and
out your fluid comes and then it's
replaced with a strong preservative
chemical
what is the strangest thing you've ever
removed
from the inside of a patient's body i
can't think of immediately of something
that i've
pulled out from inside a body that was
strange it's more after a cremation i
would say that something that even
that's sort of
normal but it still gets me every time
is titanium hips
after they come out of a body they have
this and a cremation they have this like
beautiful bluish green patina they
almost look like
um like glamorous sake glasses what
happens
to the titanium hip you can ask for it
back that rarely happens but i love it
when a family asks for it back i'm like
yes you've come to the right place we
will do that for you
often times it's uh recycled it goes to
recycling
sometimes it's made into airplane parts
it's made into street signs
nate what's up this is rico okay rico is
fantastic rico went to the same mortuary
college
that i did he's their young and balmer
and he's very enthusiastic about being a
restorative specialist
there are certain embalmers that have
a real deep appreciation for what are
called hard cases
someone's been shot in the head someone
hasn't been found
for five days and their job is through
wax and through little gizmos and
gobbets and potions and creams
can not really make them look like
themselves but can kind of put humpty
dumpty back together again and bring
them into some resemblance of themselves
so the family can see them ready
one two three
whoa
angel lust does that happen a lot a fair
amount
you can be dead but you're never really
dead
no no no you're like no you can be
really dead
yeah the idea of angel lust which is a
post-mortem erection
is very specific to extremely rare
traumatic deaths like
you know you're suddenly shot in the
head or you're suddenly strangled or
you're suddenly have some sort of
traumatic death but
i personally have never seen it in
an older man at a nursing home so
basically it's like
decapitation in the midst of intercourse
right that's or maybe like autoerotic
asphyxiation
does that smell it's like uh
disinfectant
burnt coffee involving fluid yum the
smell that i always remember from when i
was in my anatomy cadaver lab was
formaldehyde is that something you guys
use a lot
it is but actually the the formalin that
they use in anatomy cadaver labs
is actually even more intense than
what we use in an average funeral home
that really has to have a high index
i really appreciated being able to study
the human bodies
that's what got me into science but what
i will say was not the easiest
was friday before a monday exam i would
be in the cadaver lab by myself at
midnight
nighttime sounds are happening
things moving maybe my imagination
playing tricks
scary scary stuff but i managed to get
through it and do well on the test that
was probably the first time you had any
meaningful interaction with a dead body
i mean this is kind of the american
condition
in some ways is that we go our whole
lives until
all of a sudden our mom dies most of us
if you're not a mortician or
or doctor all of a sudden you're faced
with this corpse and you have to
figure out what that means to you in an
existential way
is it spiritual is it a ghost what is it
and you're having all these reckonings
with what it is
at the worst time of your life you know
it's interesting because i unfortunately
did lose my mom
right in the middle of med school when i
was in the cadaver labs i will say it's
a very different experience
looking at a body of someone who
you don't know versus someone who is
close to you you expect to feel certain
things when you're looking at the body
of a family member that may not come
because it looks different like you know
the person based on their facial
features their structure
their little intricacies of how they
react to the way you speak
and when that's not there it almost
feels unfamiliar have you ever seen that
happen with family members or perhaps
yourself
absolutely that to me is actually the
most important reason
to be with the body it can actually be
healthy to look at the body and go
that's not mom anymore that's a shell of
her and i see that she's not suffering
anymore because she's not all grimaced
up in pain
and that can be comforting for some
people and then for other people it may
say wait she looks exactly like she did
in life she just looks like she's
sleeping and that's comforting to me i
sort of encourage people to just
sit there and let what happens happen
and not put too much pressure on
yourself to feel a certain way when
you're with a dead body because
you're grieving and what you really want
is just to let to
make sure that the only way out is
through for the velvety look and feel of
actual living tissue no
way you do not even want to know
they have these plastic like screws only
bigger that they like
stick into people's orifices so stuff
won't spill out
tell me about this i was like are you
gonna let me get away without responding
to that they're called uh av
plugs and the a and the v stand for
anal vaginal they do kind of look like
butt plugs
a plastic kind of swirly butt plug after
a
embalming because there's such pressure
in the body there's
always a chance that the body will purge
a little bit or leak a little bit
out of whatever open orifices there are
so
you basically get something like a butt
plug
after you die what is your favorite
organ to handle in the human body
ooh the brain obviously really yeah
because it feels like you are holding
the seat of the soul
because you're really like holding who
the person was
and their personality and the seed of
their intellect even if it's just
while you're transferring it to sew up
the head properly or whatever you're
doing
it just it just feels like a real
privilege to me well hepatitis
syphilis ooh positive for gonorrhea
what have you ever gone ooh before
giving someone
a test result good good good
i don't and for this one reason i don't
let anything surprise me in the room
i review things before i speak to the
patient or i review them before i call
the patient because a lot of results are
given by phone
if i'm going to be giving a result
that's life-changing in a way
i will usually ask the patient to come
in to discuss it how do you psych
yourself up to make that call
if i knew i had to deliver like
potentially life-changing difficult
medical news i would just put that off
till the end of the day i don't like to
put it off to the end of the day because
it becomes harder
i like to do it as quickly as possible
meaning as early on
and as forthcoming the more you sort of
bounce around the point the more it
causes tension between you and the
patient so i try to be
a straight shooter if you will lay out
all the facts get them to ask
questions say the news back to me so
they understand exactly what's going on
then offer
just comfort so sometimes that could be
silence
sometimes that could be answering
questions it really depends on the news
you're breaking an
individual's personality that's hearing
the news ah i love it i want you to give
me my terminal diagnosis
when the time comes tell us where my
viewers can learn more about the things
you're involved in you can just google
caitlyn mortician
or caitlin doty and find me i have a
youtube channel instagram twitter
all the usual things and if you need a
funeral clarity funerals and cremation
oh link's california
no we're not yeah not sponsored by my
very small funeral home
does chocolate cause acne or pimples
click here to find
out or see what happens when you hold
your pee for a long time right here or
right here
and as always stay happy and healthy